pop
[Musique]
viens je t'emmène à venir je t'emmène 1
wade canal
m
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
chantôme
ouais
manu
enfin
je t'emmène sens inverse
construits
viens je t'emmène venise
dans ce décor charmant
viens je t'emmène à venir
nous sommes sur une seconde allan caron
je t'emmène venir même sans le bon
dernier
oui
nous faire
évoquée
favori
d'accord on n'a pas
pigeant
dans les
concert
là
chacun mène sa vie
[Musique]
dis pas que c'est une bêtise assez comme
ça
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
rien
en somme
rae
demain je me serais
je t'emmènerai
m
au bord de la tamise
[Musique]
à
non
je voulais
oreca
je n'aurais
latendresse
c'est quelquefois le plus aimé être
heureux se trouvait à nouveau de serre
faire pour quelques instants monde en
plus avec coeur
pas des yeux
[Musique]
là en vain
la tendresse la d'anvers
latendresse
c'est quand on peut se pardonner sans
réfléchir sans avocat et sans rien se
dire c'est quand on peut se séparer sans
ce mode et sans rien casser sans rien
détruit
là
ves
[Musique]
as tu en voilà
latendresse c'est un geste à mort un
sourire quand on oublie que tous les
deux on a on dit c'est quand je veux te
dire ce thème
etc a ajouté qu'un jour ou l'autre
et d
la grèce
latendresse là
[Musique]
en baisse c'est ça la tendresse la dent
vrai
la dent may
[Musique]
dans son vieux pardessus rap et ils s'en
allaient hiver était
petit matin frileux
mon dieu
[Musique]
dimanche par semaine les autres jours
c'était la graine qu'il allait
gagné
on peut
mon dieu
on allait voir
[Musique]
tu vois
ussel
[Musique]
tenté
dans son vieux pardessus râpé
[Musique]
justement lieu
ils s'asseyent à 110 main
silencieux
mon dieu
[Musique]
ça va
[Applaudissements]
dans son vieux pardessus râper les jours
de grève
quand ils rentrent sains
[Musique]
et
nous on connaissait la chanson
tout y passait bourgeois patron la
gauche la droite même le bon dieu
chez nous
allez
c'est d'abord
que j'allais chercher
pendant qu'à lieu
sur scène
c'est con
dire que j'ai passé des années à côté de
lui sans regarder
on appelle vers les cieux
j'ai arrêté
ce sera avec lui un goût chara
est rendu
mon dieu
quand on a juste
on n'est pas
loger ces choses là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils aient droit
[Musique]
près de moi
ban
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas te fais les fleuves je ne
sais pas parler
d'amour c'est que peut-être
c'est dans lequel plus de tendresse que
de discours
holmes
ben tu sais
7 13
de te serrer
[Musique]
autant
et je
dis que tu vas te manquer
[Applaudissements]
je
mais je
bah
je
que toi
m
à
jo
oui enfin
jour anges
je
avant
je ne sais pas te consoler quand je vois
que ça ne
pas
et je m'en veux
m
lettre à ce point si maladroit
quand tu t'endors
quand je te sais pas
paddy
bien que je bave
[Musique]
on sait par le
tu vois
liban
je
une
les femmes
je rajoute
je
toi
comment
janot
on
[Musique]
mon
ou déjà fini leur découverte l'habitude
s'installe doucement on ne dit plus rien
c'est les phrases banales attenant du
soir au matin
et la table où l'on dit
à présent
sans avoir faim
et j'ai fini
est couverte
quelques mois de bonheur
ce n'est pas comme
on espère
chaque jour
quelques heureux
on échange un regard
et puis c'est tout
on se marie pour échapper
[Musique]
déjà naufrage
à une aventure qui a
doumé
[Musique]
et jeunes filles
e
d'éprouvettes nous avons
oubliée
que l'on se disait
on ne voyait ciboure et on y croyait
mais on chante au jour
à l'imparfait
or
en le temps
[Musique]
chercher
le pana
plus loin
à coudre
chagrin
[Musique]
déjà fini
e
découverte la télé tous les soirs en
rentrant avant de
le cyber
une fois de temps en temps
où
quant à elle
plaisir le dimanche
recevoir des parents
et ne rien d
et j'avais dit
là
ouverte je le sais
m
audi
les enfants de faty
alexis se poser
de type à
que tu as à tvo
de vivre assez chacun de nous supporter
allez
qui n'a rien à boire
avec les banques
la scène
il retient tas
riach ap
faudrait vivre au jour le jour afin
d'accepter
et ce qui nous entoure
bon
mollahs se bat et accroche toi
à notre amour
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vivre passionnément vie
moi
10 me demander
on hésite en est
on sourit
oui
ibra
m
et
dedans
[Musique]
quand plus rien
moi
lorsque tout s'en va dieu seul sait où
est ce qu à chaque coin
[Musique]
ça
tous
[Musique]
le quotidien evra
le jour qui vient
et
les bras
assez loin
[Musique]
d'amour sans fin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
templeuve rien
lorsque tous en vain
je saurai où
[Musique]
enfin
pour moi
une
souvent
[Musique]
voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans
dans un grand jour
et
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
ça prend mieux la lumière
et
non
c'est celui
les blancs c'est seul
il y va
et celui qui reste
c'est
sérieux d'être gay comme ça pose une
chasse à freestar brive en plus prendre
au sérieux un chambriste main tout
viendrait d'en faire une autre manière
faut pas pleurer comme ça demain ou dans
un mois tu n'y penses sera plus
l'as pontoise
comme ça
aujourd'hui c'est pour toi que je suis
venu déverser une récit
car si tu
mais sache un peu tes yeux ne crois pas
surtout
peu nous en
on s'en fout rien dit rien
il sait attendu
il m'a même
jambes
ils cherchèrent à damas
les joies
pourquoi ce désespoir
cachés au fond de moi
c'est bien ce qui est pas mal
éric plaisant mais moi quand je chante
la tendresse
c'est quelquefois un peu plus et même et
être heureux
[Musique]
o2
bien des américains font pas ça sert
cerveau quelques instants qui comme à
ses insultes commandant
les yeux
et les paroles
j'aime bien ce massage pascal
l'appareil
les filles de m
latendresse
la pétition
[Musique]
m
faux plat
bien
vivez jeudi
[Applaudissements]
dans mes cousins
[Musique]
je suis si pas
avec la voix
et puis à maintenant je sais la chanson
mythique de la maman
c'est du passé celui qui a la tête dure
qui avait tant rêvé
là je vais tout cas je me sens du papa
et non
dans son vieux pardessus frapper ils
s'en allaient l'hiver l'été dans le
petit matin et de mes profonds en egypte
[Musique]
part de l'egypte génome abattoirs qui
avec un dimanche par semaine le reste de
la semaine
la grêle a qu'une seule copie
[Musique]
dieu
mais quand on agit seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
le casser
[Musique]
ces choses là
tu
ouais
en pensant à tout âge
[Musique]
qu'ils soient à l'eau
ou bien là
[Musique]
je dors
et
me la fête continue
[Musique]